we actually have seen more than one of
these black hole mergers and we've seen
actually two about equally good although
the one that we talked about you can see
with your eyes the second one is a one
with lighter black holes and it's
they're not so heavy when the ringing is
a lot longer and you can't see it
without all the fancy data analysis and
then there's a third source which we
already published but now that we have
seen that the two or the other one where
you also believe that could very well be
a black hole here so we have three
sources let's call it three sources in
three months now if we make design
sensitivity we have improved the
apparatus by another factor of three now
how does that translate into rate it
turns out if you look with a sensitivity
three times better than we have you can
look three times deeper into the
universe that says the volume of the
universe that you're looking at is three
to the cube so that's about twenty-seven
of code 30 in round numbers so instead
of seeing one a month of these black
hole pairs we should see one or maybe
one every two days and one every day
that's gonna change the character of how
we operate completely at that moment
launched into what I call the astronomy
that's associated gravitational wave
astronomy that's going to be a big day